Nola welcome to NOLA so guys why don't
you introduce yourselves
uh
because I work at deepmind
my buddy so yeah I work on multimodal
learning and this is my friend nominee
years I also work a deep mine I'm a
research scientist work on exploration
in RL quality diversity so yeah amazing
we started on the same day actually yeah
6th of December yeah it's after so have
you seen any posters that are
interesting not really we were just
meeting people basically yeah going
around meeting people mingling yeah yeah
so fantastic what about myself I was
actually looking at the design of the
posters and like I think there are some
posters which like transmit the message
like more clearly than the others like
have like a punch line like titled and
punchline and then okay I know what I'm
getting into so I was looking at some of
those very nice yeah
go go